Although they may not be
immediately apparent,
the consequences of the uncountability
of languages are rather profound.
We'll let sigma be the set
of ASCII characters.
These are all the ones you would
need to write a computer program.
And observe that the set of strings
that represent valid python programs
is a subset of sigma star.
Each program is a finite
string after all.
And note here that I
chose python arbitrarily.
You could choose any language or
set of languages if you like.
Well, since this set is a subset
of the countable set sigma star,
we have that it is countable.
Thus, there are a countable
number of python programs.
On the other hand, consider this fact,
for any language L, we can define f sub
L to be the function that is 1
if x is in L, and 0 otherwise.
All such functions are distinct.
So the set of these functions
must be uncountable.
Or in other words, the set of functions
from sigma star to (0,1) is uncountable.
Here's the profound point.
Since the set of valid python
programs is countable, but
the set of functions is not, it follows
that there must be some functions
that we just can't write
computer programs for.
In fact,
there are uncountably many of them.
So going back to our picture
of the high school classroom,
we can see that the teacher, perhaps
without realizing it, was talking about
something much more general than
what the student ended up thinking.
There are only countably many
computer programs that can
follow a finite number of steps
as the student was thinking.
But there are uncountably many functions
that fit the teacher's definition.